[Music]
welcome to film independent presents a
virtual edition i'm live fresh senior
manager of international programs at
film independent
before we start with today's very
exciting q a i have to give some praise
to our loyal supporters
thank you to our incredible lead sponsor
the hollywood foreign press association
and our screening partner vision media
and with that i'm honored to introduce
our guest for today writer director
jonas
rasmussen
hi jonas
hi
thank you so much for taking the time to
speak with us today
um i've been wanting to watch flea ever
since i heard about it after it
premiered in sundance
and uh as a
american originally from lebanon we left
lebanon during the civil war and
uh as a teenager and came to hear a lot
of these themes in the film resonated
with me personally so i'm very excited
to have this conversation and thank you
so much for bringing this story to the
world to watch
[Music]
is
foreign
your film is about your friend amin
and the name is a pseudonym
you two created
for security reasons
and you met each other at school in the
90s in denmark
um when did you start realizing that you
wanted to make a film about i mean
um
you know making up the film came quite
late but you know i was always curious
about his story uh because as you said
he arrived to my
little danish village when i was 15
years old and he came all by himself and
played in foster care with a family
just around the corner from where i
lived and i of course was curious
already back then uh about why and and
how he had come but you know he just
didn't want to talk about it um
and then from there you know a
friendship kind of grew um and
it just wasn't a part of our
conversation but you know the curiosity
was there and then i have a background
in in radio and 15 years ago i asked him
if i could do a racial documentary about
his story
and he said he said no and he said that
he was he didn't feel ready but he also
said that he knew that he would have to
share the story at some point and when
he felt ready he would like to chat with
me
um
and so i kind of had it in the back of
my head that this was something we could
do at some point um but just trying to
figure out okay what what's the form to
tell the story in um
and then eight years ago i was invited
to this workshop in denmark called
antidotes by the combined animators and
documentary filmmakers to develop ideas
from animated documentaries um and i
thought maybe this is the way to to tell
a story and i asked him um
and this is eight years ago i asked him
and he said
and he was like okay but maybe this is
this is nice because the the fact that
he could be anonymous behind um
the animation
kind of would help him because this what
you see him is from what you hear in the
film is the very first time he told the
story
and it's not easy for him to talk about
so the fact that he could be anonymous
and still have you know control over
when
he would he he's able to share when he
would like to talk to
people about the story uh was really
what enabled him to kind of set them
free to
say okay let's let's try to do this so
it all kind of started eight years ago
with that workshop
in documentary you always want to build
this trust between you and your subject
and with this film there's there was you
know greater risk because i mean was
your friend
so were you worried about how making
this film would affect your relationship
with amin
yeah i think
i think you know
making the commentaries it's always you
know
um there's always a balance and and
really like taking care of of uh of your
subject
meanwhile also wanting to share our
story
um
but you know it was really about in the
beginning it was really about creating
this safe space for him where he felt
like okay but this is
this is okay so actually in the very
beginning um
for the first year and a half or so
uh the agreement was that we were just
trying it out
so everything is recorded at my place
it was just two of us um and the
agreement was that
if he felt like this doesn't work he
could always walk out and we would make
the film and it would be okay
and also that he kind of you know he
could always pause and say i'm not ready
to talk about this yet
so he always kind of had this backdoor
and then of course when funding came in
he kind of had to look each other in the
eyes and say okay but is this
does this feel right for you um and
luckily it felt right
and um
you had a mean lie down and close his
eyes and speak
and i mean from what i noticed from the
subtitles mainly in the present tense
um can you tell us
why this approach
and was it only a recording or did you
also do video
so everything is shot on on video as
well um
and and and you know my animation
director and the editor kind of had
access to all the video materials so
they could kind of
animate us kind of you know
pick back details from his expressions
from whatever happens in in this
in the video and put it into the
animation
um
but this thing that he's laying down and
talking present tense uh and has his
eyes closed is really something i
learned when i have a background in
radio and one of the first things i
learned was this way of interviewing uh
we have a big
we have a tradition for doing radio in
denmark we'll do radio documentaries and
this technique is very common in denmark
and it was one of the first things i
learned
and it's really about you know because
when you do radio you don't have an
image so you really need the subject to
very be very descriptive and and paint a
picture for you um
um so what we would do or what the
technique is about is
to kind of bring just something back
in a memory in a certain memory um so
for example in the beginning of the film
he's in his childhood home in the garden
with his siblings
and then i would ask him about the
location what do things look like around
you
and i would ask him what does the garden
look like what kind of kind of plants
are there what are the colors you see
what does the house look like what do
you see outside the walls
and all this you know would give us the
animators a lot of material that they
could kind of work from but it also
brought him back to the specific
situation um
and
and made him kind of
relive it and it generated new memories
and all of a sudden he would remember
details uh that was very you know
it feels very present like in his voice
you sense the presence in his voice
another way than if you just do like you
know
a headset of him retelling
um
i noticed also
i mean the animation was very moving
especially when amin
went silent
when he was contemplating
um
even though the image didn't necessarily
move but because of the sound
if everything was turned up his
breathing shifting
in his seat or on
the bed where he was lying um or even in
the flashback everything was and
was that from your experience working in
radio because it also reminded me a
little bit of like the sound i hear in
good podcasts like where all the sound
is so intensified for us to know where
where we are
yeah but definitely you know because
this film in its call is a documentary
and i thought there was so much you know
detail in just his voice and and how he
kind of
made little breaks and you know little
expressions that you hear in in
in just you know a sigh or something um
so it was important to kind of really
nourish this in the sound design so you
had a feeling that beneath the animation
that's real person like lying and and
and you need to feel that throughout the
phone
the animation um was hand wrong uh
rotoscoping i don't know if i'm correct
uh
yeah no
it's not rotoscope it is hand drawn to
the animation um but you know they had
access to the interviews so
it's all based on video footage uh but
they didn't put you know
video footage underneath and draw it on
top of that all these they drew it in
hand
and then they could always you know like
take references from the video
recordings and put it into the image
the other thing that i noticed that was
very interesting um was that you
usually in documentary film is the other
way around where we use animation to
recreate reenact scenes that we don't
have footage of
but for you and your film it was
reversed and used the live action
uh archival footage
you know projected here and there um
very strategically but
like very impactfully can we talk about
the decision behind
using this live action and not also
animating
yeah um but you know again because it's
it's in this course of documentary i
thought it was important to remind
people throughout that that that the
reason
we hear the story the reason i mean is
pushed out of afghanistan is for
historical reasons and we need to see
that we need to see that
all these things happening to him is
because of things that happened in our
world in the real world
and also again
we use a lot of archive
as reference for the animation so we
would have you know
i would do a lot of research finding
archive footage from afghanistan and 80s
and then you know we would see things
and it would take directly from that
color footage and animate it and put it
into the animation as well so it felt
like it kind of
you could go from one thing to the other
seamlessly and and and just so it felt
connected um but it was really important
to me that that that to remind people
throughout that this is this is a real
story it's a real person it's not
fiction
yeah i thought it was really impactful
and especially these scenes
from
afghanistan
prior to
you know
the taliban or the mujahideen rule i
thought that was really interesting and
important to show also especially in the
west
uh
how society changed for for this family
or how you know the situation their
country changed so that became so
unbearable they had to leave
um
you also
chose a non-linear storytelling going
from you know the past to the present
can we talk about this approach as well
and
um
you know i had some feelings why but i
would love to hear
your thoughts on that and why you chose
a non-linear storytelling
yeah of course
but you know um
you know this film is really also about
uh how it affects a person to not being
able to
share his story
um so this going back and forth in time
like we have the present day where he
slowly you know opens up and i really
wanted to show
uh how you know he slowly came to terms
with his path
and how it changed him um
so going back and forth and see how he
struggled in his in his relationship
with his partner in denmark at the same
time you see his his sorry kind of
unfolding um and you know both stories
are kind of similar they're both stories
about
uh finding a home
um
um so it felt like
uh
when we started when i started doing the
film they were
accidentally luckily uh trying to find a
house and it really mirrored
the story of
a young man uh having to um
flee his home in afghanistan and
going to search for a new place so it
felt very natural to kind of combine
these two stories uh because they they
fundamentally about the same thing
yeah i mean for me it did
do that and it reflected how for
children who grew up in war
or are refugees
the past is never gone it's always
lingering in the past and kind of affect
what
our decisions and how we interact with
the world in in the present
but it also in a way
reflected i mean cultural intersexuality
where he
throughout the film maybe until the end
you don't feel that he's completely in
the present right so and then you um the
way you approach the film with him
laying down i thought it was
um
really
as if he is you know going
through a self therapy right to face
that glass and see how he can
live in the present um
yeah and and and i didn't realize this
you know going in for me this was a
please nigga interviewing um but i
didn't know what he was carrying around
you know when we started um so he
himself said at the very first interview
he told me um i i don't care if this
film is going to be made to me it's
therapeutical just to share my story
um
so i didn't realize until we actually
got started that this was the situation
for him and i didn't know all this that
he was carrying around and how much it
affected him in every day of his life
um
so it really to me and in the process of
making project it really grew uh from
being one thing from being me
really wanting to know his secret and
then to see okay but this is really
something he cares around everything he
does
because i mean i mean the film has his
themes of family survival
sacrifice sacrificing for the family
um you know the definition of what is
home or where is home but it's you know
but it is a double coming out story
right in the film he we we learned how
he came out
as a gay man to his family
um and we'll talk about this uh
in a second because it's really
interesting
but also coming out to you and the world
about the secret that he's held
um so it's really
interesting um
and then you know coming out
to his family i mean
um
lgbtq films especially about coming out
often uh in documentary at least or
about you know oppression and getting
out of this oppression as a gay man um
and
um
the way you tell a means coming out
story
coming of age as a young gay man or
young gay boy it's heartbreaking but it
never
feels exploited it always feels like a
celebration
of your friend
and
yeah and
i mean how
cautious were you
of like
because it felt very succinct
and there's just these
elements that without like really
exploiting it and making it dramatic i
don't know can we talk a little bit how
and this is your second film with a gay
subject matter too because i believe
what he did
and then also what attracts you to
telling stories from lgbt from the lgbtq
community
um
but you know first of all i i
eminem came out to me when he was 16.
um so to me that it was like a natural
part of his story you know that he was
gay and i wanted to feel that way in the
film as well
but then you know in the process of
making the film i realized that that it
as you said it's a double coming out
story and and that this story of him
having to hide his sexuality for all
this youth uh is kind of the same thing
as when he arrived that might get to
hide his past he couldn't talk that's
always been a part of him that he
couldn't talk about
so so so these stories really
intertwined and i realized that while
doing the film
um but you know um
him being gay was never uh
it was it just felt natural and i wanted
it to feel the same uh in the film that
was it's just a part of his personality
um
what goes into these kind of stories i
think i've always had you know an
interest in
in
in marginalized people um
so whether it's
a refugee or a gay person or
uh
whatever might not be around the world i
i
i have
a sincere interest in
how people cope uh and what people do to
kind of deal with um and trying to break
out of being marginalized
um
so that's that i think i don't have a
specific interest in lgbt a few
stories
i just happen to have done two in a row
um but it's really about you know nice
people where i'm interested to see how
people go
more and more we we realized that the
importance of people
from under represented communities
telling their own stories
um
were you worried in today's climate to
tell a story about gay muslim
refugees from afghanistan
you know and
was that the reason for
telling us so early on your personal
connection to i mean i think in the
first 10 minutes you established this
very personal connection
to the country
no but you know i think to me um
i never
had an intention to do a refugee story
or an afghani story uh it was always a
story about um my friend and a
friendship and that was kind of what
started the whole thing um and
and this thing about having
a close friend where
he has a secret something he doesn't
talk about and how that affects the
relationship that was kind of where it
started
um
so i really had a feeling that okay but
of course then the project changed then
we had the refugee crisis in europe in
2015 and and also that's okay but this
is also about
you know
giving refugees a human face
because a lot of the time refugees are
described only by what they need they
need something
but here because it's told from within a
friendship
i could give a lot more nuance to the
refugee story i could give because you
know being a refugee is not an identity
it's it's a circumstance it's a
situation you you live through um and
and and but you're so much more and and
he was so much more so read to be able
to
to give a human face to a refugee story
and let i mean kind of represent
refugees in a way where you feel okay
but
um you know they're complex
individuals like everyone else
so it became increasingly important to
me but it all kind of originated from
from the friendship
yeah and also for me
like establishing this early on also
made me realize
that
you know
stories of refugees in
europe or in denmark in this case also
we you're telling us that how it
affected uh you as a person meeting i
mean and how that changed you as a
person learning about you know the uh
the world outside your you know very
safe and
idyllic village um so in denmark so i
thought that's what's really important
to establish
um
the other thing that
resonated and
depicted this really close friendship
between you when you talked about
jean-claude van damme and how you two
had
uh two different experiences with this
movie star and
you know some of these charming moments
um
in the film depicting the innocent
crushes that i mean had on hollywood and
bollywood uh leading men
why was it so why was it important for
you to inject this humor throughout the
film
um you know which is
for the most part it's very heavy
and um you know emotional
but you know i think um
i think it goes from most relationships
actually that that when you're able to
laugh together
it creates connection and that creates
empathy um and i felt like you know
because we i mean me we laugh a lot
together
so it kind of it had to be in the film
and i had a hope that if if the audience
were able to laugh with them in as well
it creates the same connection between
the audience and i mean as there's in
our friendship so this thing about you
know cracking people open
by having them laugh with him and at him
because also you know he's also
you know he's flawed he's lying by his
boyfriend he's not saying he's going to
the states and we as an audience see
that and then we can kind of
and that it just makes him more human
and and creates this connection where
you
hopefully feel empathy to autism
yeah and it is universal having crushes
on movie stars and
you know pop idols and so forth so i
again
i thought that was really
interesting how you brought this in and
and um speaking about that in cinema
a portrayal of a monthly gay man is
always about oppression
how hard it is but the film
um puts this prejudice which most people
have about gay men and muslim families
to shame i mean even for us as an
audience in the west
when i mean
brother
after i mean comes after him taking him
somewhere
i feel like in our mind we were thinking
something completely different and then
when it was revealed that he was taking
him to his first
gay bar
it sort of like
forced us as an audience to face our own
preconceived notions about muslim
families
um
i loved it because
even though i come from lebanon and i'm
more familiar with amin's world you know
because lebanon had
a large quantum population
i still
was really surprised by that can we talk
a little bit about
writing that scene and
um
and why you know this approach to this
scene
but it's definitely you know it i really
wanted to kind of show the prejudices on
this topic but it really comes from
amin's own prejudice against his own
family because the reason why he didn't
come out early on
was because he he had these prejudices
against his own i mean he thought that
they would cut him off he thought that
he would lose them when he came out
um
and i really wanted that to be a part of
the film so of course i i used the
cinematic toolbox to kind of extend the
suspense
because of course when amin is walking
down you know
towards the gate club he
knew that it was a gay club because
like
i told it before it went in there but i
wanted to keep this because i really
wanted to to
display amin's own prejudice against his
own family and the relief that he felt
when they accepted him
so um
me and the editor we really tried so we
got okay how can we display this in this
scene
to make sure that you you get the same
sense
of prejudice and the same sense of
relief that amin had when he finally
dared to
to to come
out um another way that you know these
preconceived notions that we have
uh are
the challenge is with the
counter
first the original score by uno
helmersen was hauntingly beautiful
um
subtle but yet tugged on your emotions
throughout the the film
but you also use european and american
pop music
like aha blasting from the walkman
uh were these songs that i mean listened
to
um
yeah i mean i was what was
so one of the first like actually the
first interview i did where i kind of i
asked him to just go back in like to his
early memories the first memories he had
he started quite immediately to talk
about this walkman that his sister had
given him this pink walkman
and he i then asked him what music he
listened to and and he decided to talk
about these pop songs that i listened to
myself like rock said and aha and
whitney houston and madonna and all
these you know big star names
and i was somewhat surprised by that but
you know i really enjoyed the fact
that that you know um i could relate
a lot more to
his childhood because you know
we're the same age we listen to the same
music we've seen the same films so just
the fact that
yeah i really wanted to bring that into
the film so other people could be late
and see okay but here's an afghan kid
you know in kabul listening to aha and
like we all did in 84.
yeah exactly and it makes this far away
setting seem not so foreign and
relatable um
the pseudonym
amin
is an arabic name popular throughout the
muslim world
in arabic it means faithful but it also
means honest
and amin's journey in this film is to be
finally honest and not keep secrets was
because i know it's a pseudonym was the
name choice intentional or coincidental
it was i i i read up on a lot of
arabic names kind of practically which
one would fit uh his character so it's
it's it's definitely not coincidences
okay great i mean for me because i see
arabic
it's uh i noticed that so that's great
um
a
british actor with ahmed who recently
launched the muslim representation
initiative
which is a fund to support muslim
filmmakers and storytellers and danish
actor nikolai koster although people
will know him from jameson
um came on board
your film can we talk about how
they came on board and how did that help
also
the film
so it it they came on quite late in the
process um a little bit before the film
premiered at sundance um and it was
really my
our sales agent idea who thought okay
but it would be great to do an english
stop version of the film
i was a little reluctant at the
beginning because i think there's so
much you know in a minute's own voice
and we really haven't talked about
before i really worked a lot on
nourishing you know the authenticity and
the voice
uh but to a point you know if
we could get a story like this out to a
broader audience by having an enemy stop
version and big name on it um it of
course would not attend
so it was really about trying to find
the good cast
anime getting you know wrist was
my favorite pick
first of all because he's incredibly
talented um
but also because he as you said he
fights for representation uh in film um
and it took a while before we could get
a hold on it of him but finally we've
got the phone to him and he saw it and
he was really eager to
to support it um
and with nikolai it was a little easier
he lives like like 10 miles from my
place in copenhagen so it was about like
you know
just getting a hold of him um but he
also has a lot of work for unhcr and
it's the two cloud movement um so he was
really supportive so we've done an
english operation
where ris is a min and nuclei is me and
it's going to be out at some point as
well
um the film was initially slated to
premiere at khan
in 2020 but
because of kovitz pandemic
it was the festival was cancelled i
believe there was still online
version of it but then a flea premiered
at sundance in 2021
and ironically
as the film began to screen worldwide
and get all these accolades it coincided
with the american control from
afghanistan and then suddenly i mean
story was no longer something from the
past
it was something that we were seeing in
front of our eyes on the tv again it it
makes us feel that nothing changes
um in this world how has this experience
you know the success of the film but
then seeing what's happening now in
afghanistan
affect you and i mean i mean sort of
like
seems like bittersweet but
no
yeah no no it's you know it's just sadly
relevant i mean i would i i really wish
it wasn't as relevant as it is um
but you know to see
there's the sequence where i mean and
his family flee afghanistan speakable um
and you know i've me personally i of
course google close
tied to afghanistan while working on
this film and working on that specific
sequence for you know weeks and months
and then to also see
almost identical footage on the news was
just heartbreaking um but you know of
course even more so far i mean
um
i'm in touch with him all the time and
he was very affected but with everything
that happened and and um
despite but all of a sudden a new
generation of afghans are getting pushed
out of the country um
that's going to be in the same limbo as
he was in for years and not being able
to choose their own player path in life
and he still has you know relatives in
afghanistan who was some really bad
situation so it's it was
a very difficult time and still is um
yeah you know it's just
just operating
um
the last shot of the film um was very
moving because you dissolved from
animation to live action
as if you know i mean might one day to
step out from behind
and share but
it felt hopeful to me
um
at least for a mean story
um
perhaps
he
found home
are you hopeful
i'm hopeful for his story for sure um
and and um
you know um
he's he's he's definitely in a good
place now and he really found a place
where he feels at home and you know um
i mean has been traveling a lot for many
many years um and then they bought this
house and he didn't he was he thought he
was gonna you know continue traveling
but as everyone else also he was stuck
in the in his house in his home for two
years
almost
um
but he actually really enjoyed it
um
and he sends me photos all the time of
the flowers in the garden
um so um he's definitely in a good place
and found out
he told me that he can see himself get
over there so that's amazing
um
i've been uh i mean a fan of danish film
and television
and series ever since i discovered
borgen
um and every year i look out for
denmark's submission to the oscars
and for denmark which is one of the
smaller european countries and i believe
a population of 6 million
has like 13 films nominated and i think
it holds the record with like bigger
countries like spain and japan
um you know and then the frank's little
bit below italy and france and you have
had four wins
um
what is denmark's secret
i think there's different things um
one is as there's an amazing film school
denmark so the quality of the craft like
the editors the the sound designers uh
the dops coming out of that school like
the standard is just incredibly high and
they work not not just in denmark but
from around the world on films
and it's really specialized in in
nurturing the artistic mission of
different
people in the schools of different
crowds
um but also we're fortunate to have
you know a funding system that supports
uh
uh films not just speak films but also
artistic films and support the new time
talent coming out so
um
i feel very lucky
to be
to live in denmark in the system that
kind of supports the arts and the way it
does
well it works because um we're always
looking out to see uh
what's coming out of denmark and see is
the
denmark's oscar submission to the
international film category there's a
lot of buzz about it also being
maybe nominated for best animation film
that's not only best supplementary but
best oh and also best documentary and
maybe even
best picture so i'm rooting for it i
wish you all the luck and
thank you so much for
taking the time to speak with us today
um i really love the film and
is going to be um recent theaters here
in the us
by neon and participants on december 3rd
so make sure you
thank you thank you so much thanks for
having me
[Music]
you